bienvenue à tous ravie de vous retrouver
ici au proto 204 pour le tout premier
numéro de Paris Saclay le mag de 2015 le
proto 214 vous connaissez c'est un lieu
d'échange de rencontre un connecteur
d'innovation technologique mais pas
seulement vous pouvez un cela dans un
instant la technologie elle est
omniprésente ici à Paris Saclay à suivre
un petit détour par NeuroSpin pour une
immersion dans nos cerveaux grâce à
l'IRM l'imagerie pas résonance
magnétique un petit ours sportif en vélo
à la soufflerie de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux et enfin une
pause bien méritée à la Maison de
l'étudiant à ne pas manquer non plus
notre agenda toute l'actualité en bref
et en images ce sera à la fin de cette
émission
voici deux exemples parmi tant d'autres
de la technologie du territoire mais
l'innovation de Paris-Saclay doit aller
plus loin d'où cette initiative lancée
ici au proto 204 celle d'une économie
collaborative et d'une innovation
sociale comment améliorer le quotidien
des habitants comment faire remonter les
idées les projets et les moins de
réponse avec Alima embrapti chargée de
projet de l'établissement public Paris
Saclay
aujourd'hui on a organisé une journée
qui s'appelait Paris Saclay à l'heure de
l'économie collaborative l'innovation
sociale l'idée l'objectif c'est de
questionner ce territoire très
estampillé innovation scientifique
innovation technologique sur sa capacité
à innover autrement
il existe des porteurs de projets des
associations qui travaillent sur des
thématiques beaucoup plus sociales ou
qui touchent à l'environnement ou à
l'économie collaborative et qui peuvent
être également innovantes et donc c'est
vraiment cette question là qu'on a voulu
poser aujourd'hui à toute l'assemblée
des participants
on a eu près de 10 porteurs de projets
du territoire de Paris Saclay qui sont
venus nous développer leur objectif et
un peu parler de ce qui leur manquait en
termes d'outils en termes de financement
aujourd'hui il y a smart auto-stop Smart
auto-stop c'est la première application
qui va mettre en relation des piétons
qui prennent les transports en commun ou
qui ont des difficultés pour se déplacer
avec les automobilistes qui leur passent
devant et donc ça vient compléter
l'offre de transport existante
le stop en fait pour des raisons de
sécurité
arrêter son développement et grâce aux
applications smartphones et notamment
smartphone aujourd'hui on est capable de
non seulement géolocaliser les gens dans
la rue donc de les mettre en relation en
temps elle mais on est surtout aussi
capable d'utiliser notation de la
communauté pour donner une sécurité dans
le service qui est essentiel au
développement du stop en ville
grâce aux partenariats qu'on a avec les
entreprises du plateau de Saclay donc
via l'association pôle vie donc qui
contient le CEA Danone Thalès
Polytechnique l'ONERA etc on est en
train de lancer courant décembre et sur
les quatre prochains mois la première
expérimentation
de d'auto-stop intelligent sur un
territoire aussi grand et l'objectif
c'est de déployer ce service sur toute
l'Île-de-France courant 2015
on est quand même très fiers d'avoir ces
porteurs de projets qui nous rappellent
que Paris Saclay innove autrement que
technologiquement
et pourquoi ne pas utiliser
l'application Smart auto-stop pour se
rendre à Bures-sur-Yvette à la maison de
l'étudio qui est juste derrière moi
comme vous pouvez le constater elle
n'est pas tout à fait terminée mais l'un
des architectes Cyril Hanat nous a
ouvert les portes de cette bâtisse
écologique qui veut s'intégrer dans cet
univers boisé un bâtiment qui abrite une
salle de spectacle des studios
d'enregistrement et une cafétéria XXL
pareil sa clé le Mag vous propose une
visite en avant-première
la Maison de l'étudiant c'est un cadeau
de la région Île-de-France à
l'Université Paris-Sud il voulait un
lieu où les étudiants puissent avoir
diverses activités associatives des
spectacles des des moments de vie des
studios de d'enregistrement etc
nous l'idée c'était un peu de continuer
la forêt le décomposer les formes en les
transformant en forme géométrique et de
faire donc un bâtiment qui était
entièrement en bois mais qui est comme
une forêt qui se transforme en un objet
de science un objet de restitution un
objet informatique
le point le plus important de la maison
d'étudiant ça sera la cafétéria et on
l'a agrandi des mesures aimants elle
devait faire 30 mètres carrés et ce que
vous voyez derrière moi ici ça en fait
tout est géré dans le bâtiment pour que
il y ait une optimisation de la lumière
naturelle bien sûr ce bâtiment est un
bâtiment extrêmement écologique c'est un
bâtiment à basse consommation qu'il a
été par choix bien avant que les normes
l'imposent
il y a tout plein de choses tout plein
d'activités qui sont possibles dans ce
bâtiment la grande salle c'est la salle
polyvalente qui est une salle de
spectacle professionnelle elle est
elle-même connectée à toute une zone de
studio d'enregistrement qui sera à la
disposition des étudiants
il y a des zones qui sont dédiées aux
jeux aux jeux de société au jeu vidéo il
y a des salles multifonctions qui
servent à tout le monde pour les
réunions les exposés etc il y a des
petits bureaux pour les différentes
associations toutes ces salles se
convergent ici vers cette cafétéria où
il y a toutes les activités et qui
elle-même s'ouvrent vers l'extérieur
à 50 mètres d'ici il y a chez Yvette qui
a toujours été un haut lieu culturel de
la culture rock et du rap de la musique
dans la vallée de Chevreuse on aimerait
que ici il se passe d'autres choses qui
répondent en fait à la Maison de
l'étudiant qui a un dialogue entre les
deux qui s'instaure des échanges de avec
des activités variées et différentes
ne cherchez pas son équivalent NeuroSpin
est un centre de recherche neurologique
unique en son genre il mêle
neurosciences et physique ces
scientifiques plonge dans les recoins de
notre cerveau grâce à l'IRM l'imagerie
par résonance magnétique une recherche
qui permet de mieux comprendre des
maladies comme Alzheimer Parkinson ou
encore la sclérose en plaques regardez
neuro spin est une infrastructure du CEA
qui a ouvert en 2007 et qui est destiné
à l'exploration du cerveau et cette
exploration est réalisée à l'aide de
grands instruments ce sont des IRM qui
sont installés donc dans le dans le
bâtiment
le bâtiment comprend deux parties quand
vous arrivez vous avez des grandes
arches et dans chaque arche vous avez un
instrument une IRM à très hauts champs
dans une des arches NeuroSpin on a un ni
majeur à trois Tesla un 3 Tesla dans le
domaine clinique c'est du haut de gamme
les hôpitaux il y en a une quarantaine
en France Topito qui ont saisir et
matthrée Auchan pour X pour le cerveau
donc nous on a déjà une IRM après Auchan
de base ensuite on a une IRM à 7 Tesla
qui est une IRM donc qui est un très
très Auchan et qui permet de faire une
observation beaucoup plus fine il y en a
une trentaine dans le monde en service
qu'une seule en France en service donc
là vraiment on est au stade du prototype
bientôt on aura donc dans le cas d'un
projet franco-allemand quel projet un
IRM à 11,7 Tesla pour l'observation donc
du cerveau chez l'homme qui sera une
première mondiale et qui devrait arriver
d'ici la fin de l'année
on travaille donc sur le cerveau à la
fois on recherche fondamentale pour
comprendre le fonctionnement du cerveau
par exemple la lecture on essaie de
comprendre comment se fait
l'apprentissage de lecture chez l'enfant
et donc on a déduit des principes
d'apprentissage de lecture on travaille
également dans le domaine appliqué pour
pouvoir identifier ce qu'on appelle des
biomarkers qui ont permis de
caractériser des pathologies par exemple
la pathologie d'Alzheimer et puis on
travaille également dans l'exploration
de nouvelles thérapeutiques pour
certaines maladies et qui touchent le
cerveau on travaille également donc en
psychiatrie sur différents couples
psychiatriques
est un centre du CEA qui accueille des
équipes externes et donc il est intégré
dans le plateau de Saclay il participe
donc à toute la mise en place des
structures de du plateau de Saclay tous
les groupes de travail dans ce domaine
à quelques kilomètres de là à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux ce ne sont plus
nos cerveaux qui sont à l'étude mais
l'aérodynamique en automobile n'est pas
seulement la SIA la Société des
ingénieurs de l'automobile mais c'est
soufflerie au service de la petite reine
notre équipe a assisté à ces tests
grandeurs nature avec des cyclistes nous
avons rencontré Vincent Martin Neuville
le directeur du GIE S2A et ses équipes
une soufflerie c'est un conduit en
boucle fermée ici on a un ventilateur
d'un côté et de l'autre côté on a une
zone de test dans lequel on teste des
objets ou dans ce cas là des cyclistes
le ventilateur entraîne le flux d'air
dans le conduit en boucle
et on a débit constant donc on se
retrouve avec une zone de test ou le ou
l'air arrive sur le l'objet testé ce qui
est important c'est que l'air se déplace
de façon homogène et arrive de façon
homogène sur l'objet à tester
en soufflerie on réalise la mesure de
scix directement un coefficient qui
veulent donner l'effort de traîner à
héros et on mesure aussi ce qu'on
appelle la pression dynamique c'est la
pression qu'on sent quand on met la main
par la fenêtre dehors et ça nous donne
ce coefficient de SCX qui va
caractériser la qualité aérodynamique de
l'objet ou de du cycliste à tester
la qualité de la soufflerie le plus
qu'elle a c'est d'être une grande veine
donc ça c'est assez nouveau en standard
de pouvoir tester les interactions entre
cycliste et de regarder ce qui se passe
quand on est dans le sillage d'optimiser
sa position dans le sillage du cycliste
devant soi et ça c'est un gros plus
les origines de ce projet c'est le
projet de construction du du Vélodrome à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
on a savoir faire en terme
d'optimisation aérodynamique pour
l'automobile pourquoi ne pas faire
profiter le monde du cyclisme et plus
particulièrement le monde de la FFC
nos clients principaux sont les
constructeurs automobiles donc
l'opportunité que présentait la
construction du Vélodrome c'est un moyen
pour nous d'élargir notre périmètres de
compétences
vis-à-vis du dos mais aussi vis-à-vis de
l'aéronautique c'est faire connaître
notre savoir-faire dans d'autres
filières industrielles
le territoire est très dynamique j'en
veux pour preuve de l'autre côté de
notre implantation de l'autre côté du
boulevard vient de s'implanter Mercedes
il y a le siège de BMW etc donc ça
prouve que que le dynamisme il est là
avant de nous quitter tout ça vos
agendas voici les événements à ne pas
rater à Paris sa clé avec d'abord
l'enquête publique sur le contrat de
développement territorial Paris Saclay
Versailles
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
Vélizy-Villacoublay ce projet sera
présenté au grand public le jeudi 5
février à 20h à l'université interrage
de Versailles et le lundi 9 février à
20h30 à l'UGC Ciné Cité de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux c'est de réunions
publiques sont ouvertes à tous
évidemment le lancement aussi de la
deuxième édition du Challenge étudiant
Paris Saclay imaginez le campus du futur
vous avez jusqu'au premier mars pour
vous inscrire et présentez-vous sur
studica.com le 12 février tous à
l'aéroport d'Orly pour techni 9 le plus
grand rendez-vous européen dédié à
l'innovation 1600 décideurs plus de 9000
rendez-vous B2B a noté à 14h aura lieu
une table ronde consacrée au secteur
stratégique de Paris Saclay avec Sanofi
Alstom dji et
enfin du 16 au 19 février c'est le
festival d'hiver à Jouy-en-Josas des
troupes de théâtre étudiantes viennent
du monde entier et s'installe au campus
HEC avis aux amateurs pour plus
d'informations notre site internet
epps.fr
et c'est déjà la fin de ce premier
numéro de Paris cette clé le mag de 2015
on se retrouve très vite pour toujours
plus d'informations sur votre territoire
d'ici là vous pourrez voir ou revoir
cette émission sur votre site internet à
très vite